here we are for the eighth and final
season of Game of Thrones
congratulations on making it this far
thank you was there ever a point in the
series when you thought you were gonna
get axed earlier yeah and sometimes a
really significant points and other
times it could just be a general kind of
malaise of anxiety I certainly didn't
know I mean I I die
no one knew but I didn't feel confident
that I would make it through to the end
so each season I was very prepared to
die off-screen I think that's just the
best way of dealing with disappointment
talk to me about your reaction when you
read the script for your final episode I
mean I thought they did an amazing job
overall whatever the whole season but
with Jamie also just really yeah it made
sense and it wasn't was very in them
feel very true to the to this show and
to this character and from this Brienne
of Tarth how are you feeling about her
it took me a long time to actually
digest the storyline this season and the
final episode it's a strange thing isn't
it because I've never made any
particular plans or deliberate plans
about where I thought that character
would end up but you'll never prepare
for what will actually happen
but I did a good job
how have the two of you been preparing
for the end of Game of Thrones has taken
up so much of your time
what's been going through your head
Sophie told us that she had to take a
minute and kind of like recollection
through a bit of an identity crisis oh
really
well you know I don't think I really
have for that maybe it's gonna hit me in
the future but you know it ended and
then it's something else started but
we're still it's it's weird because you
still feel like you're doing this
because we're sitting here and now at
the premiere but I don't know how have
you dealt with leaving Game of Thrones
did you have an identity crisis
I think the identity crisis I've had has
been doing the show I mean that every
day I remind myself that this is this is
phenomenal and I'm incredibly lucky to
experience it and if this is going to
end soon so to just enjoy every day but
you know different things come and go
and you can't artistically really place
too much emphasis on one thing you can
thoroughly enjoy and and reap the
wonderful benefits of it but um you
can't find you can't place too much
emphasis on on work because it's a
family and your opinion who do you think
deserves
Nikolaj coster-waldau not Jaime
Lannister coster-waldau deserves at the
Iron Throne yeah and it's it's consensus
about that and a real dragon where
that's what they gave you anything
yeah if it gave me a real dragon yeah
the lead characters they gave a real
weed right I had to I had to you know
yeah and it was part of an amazing
ceremony that took place it was salute
afield but what it didn't feature human
sacrifice it featured dragon egg
implantation and it was very moving
that's wonderful we're gonna wrap things
up with a quick game and it's called
game of phones yes you tell me which of
your co-stars
these scenarios apply to rapid fire who
did you text first about what happens to
you in your final episode him which of
your co-stars take the best selfies on
set I don't know I am boring and just
concentrate okay that's a kid who sends
the funniest memes in the Game of
Thrones group chat Alfie Allen yes uh
who would be your one phone call if you
were in jail well it wouldn't be anyone
from Game of Thrones a lawyer I think
Nikolaj coster-waldau
[Music]